einen tag nach dem rückzug von partei
und fraktionschefs schäuble will heute
das cdu präsidium über die neue lage
beraten
ihr könnt sie alle leute die tagesschau
wahrscheinlich eine der erfolgreichsten
und bekanntesten sendungen ganz
deutschland jeden abend schauen
millionen von menschen und ziehen sich
daraus ihre nachrichten und manchmal
manchmal passiert dabei der eine oder
andere fehlt das ganze ist dann meistens
relativ geil unterhaltsam weil die
tagesschau einerseits besonders
professionell zu sein und andererseits
auch zwangsweise irgendwelche sachen
schief laufen und wie die moderatoren
reagiert das ist immer ziemlich geil wie
ziel sollte die besten tagesschau fans
rein leute let's go ja genau das ist es
leute das sind diese sendung ist einfach
so professionell da diese sendung
schreit deutsche professionalität alles
auf die millisekunde genau jeder kann
seinen text perfekt jeder weiß ganz
genau was seine rolle ist außer halt
manchmal nicht
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
susanne daubner darüber die kameras ob
wir daraus die denkt gerade das wird
irgendwann laufen millionen von menschen
in ganz deutschland schauen hier zu
haben an ihrem arbeitstag wirklich
professionellste arbeit geleistet als
ingenieure als ärzte sonst wo auch immer
als pflegekraft ich weiß es nicht und
denken sich die ja ich hab so rheingas
hätte jetzt mal professionelles
entertainment können
susanne daubner hat keinen bock jetzt
legenden besagen susanne daubner wartet
immer noch bis die sendung anfängt am
vierten tag nach der währungsumstellung
hat sich der euro bereits weitgehend
eine gewohnheit jeder zweite kunde zu
jeder zweite kunde jeder zweite kunde
hat die euro umstellung noch nicht als
positiv wohlgemerkt alle anderen
nationen durchaus die italiener die
griechen die albania die türken alle
alle sind fein damit nur die kurden
haben wieder keinen bock am vierten tag
nach der währungsumstellung hat sich der
euro bereits weitgehend eingebürgert in
der 2
[Gelächter]
ich weiß nicht was diese leute aber
irgendwas bei diesem tagesschau fans
gibt mir einfach so was besonderes wenn
in irgendeiner anderen sendung fehlt
sind ist es auch schon okay im plan
lustig aber die tagesschau leute ich hab
doch gesagt die dass paul die
professionellste seriöser sendung
eigentlich mit der deutschen fernsehen
jeder zweite kunde zahlt nach angaben
des einzelhandels in deutschland
inzwischen mit der neuen währung stoppen
bei den banken auf den euro sie ist
heute erstmals etwas nach jeder zweite
kurze zeit wird im neuesten euro ok
interessante informationen muss man
wirklich sagen vielen dank
wie heißt das ist doch wie heißt ja
nochmal jens riewa ist das glaube ich
dass ich gut gemacht wir haben alle mann
jens riewa und
winfrey war vielen dank nochmal für das
update was die ganzen kurden mit dem
euro machen das wird morgen überall
sonnig
wir hätten zwischen -2 grad weniger
erzählst du noch mehr von den kurden
ich weiß nicht mal aufs tableau wenn das
wetter war was halten die kunden vom
wetter das kann man kann es auch mal
sagen wie viele kurden finden dieses
wetter akzeptabel
jeder zweite oder mehr oder weniger
sind auf sendung es hat mir niemand
gesagt hat und diese moderatoren junge
macht euch kein bild was für ein horror
das für ein monster so sein muss um die
tagesschau zu moderieren
glaub mal du musst durch die hölle gehen
du musst so viele sachen können
jahrzehnte berufserfahrung haben diese
menschen die das moderieren haben einen
kranken anspruch an sich selbst werde
ich mit euch safe und dann stellte vor
was in den vorwürfen die so reden und
dann erfahren so die sendung werde
sofort rot die werdet merken wir so eine
hitze in euch hochschießen checkt die
dga ich habe gerade vor millionen von
deutschen einfach reingeschossen kraft
krass aber auch es ist wirklich krass
leute wie diese moderatorin dann auch
den turnaround zu machen wie die sofort
wieder professionell werden die haben
gerade denke es ist wirklich so müsst
euch vorstands wildtiere in der schule
vor der ganzen schule einen vortrag
halten
auf einmal reißt eure rose so und die
steht auf der bühne und was diese leute
für maschinen sind diese wirklich so ok
roses gerissen die macht irgendwie so
ein witz ja okay jetzt habe ich ein
bisschen bessere belüftung dann können
wir weitermachen mit dem vortrag und die
sind direkt wieder im modus krank
warum sagte sealife ist susanne du bist
[Musik]
hässlich kommt neuen ausgabe der
tagesschau die heutigen themen
wir schauen unserer moderatorin susanne
daubner dabei zu wie sie einfach los das
ist unsere moderatoren zusammen nach
sich halt einfach lust für sie wir haben
keine bären keine informationen
eine nachrichtenseite moderator
es ist ich habe mitleid mit diesen
leuten wirklich gut ich hab nicht
mitleid damit dass sie wahrscheinlich
ein arsch voll kohle bekommen
damit muss ich einmal in meiner position
als auch kein mitleid haben das ist ich
glaube damit komme ich schon ganz gut
selbst ja aber leute ganz ehrlich komma
wir waren doch alle schon an dem punkt
wo wir in der situation waren wo wir
nicht lachen sollen
wir sollten du weißt einfach die jetzt
hier lacher wenn ich jetzt hier bin ich
der allerletzte mensch ganz einfach so
und jetzt stellt euch vor ort in dieser
situation sehen euch 357 millionen leute
zu wort ich bin jetzt live bruder wenn
ich jetzt nicht gebacken kriegen wir
noch gott helfen ja meine damen und
herren wir sind wir kassieren nur
hunderte von millionen bis milliarden
von ihren rundfunkbeiträge da hat jetzt
in dem fall leider nicht dafür gereicht
eine stabile verbindung nach china
aufzubauen da sind wir einfach nicht
dazu in der lage gewesen jetzt gerade
ja ich bin sicher sie verteilen und da
und geben uns im nächsten jahr noch mal
die doppelte geldmenge wir haben die
eingeschlossenen männer auf diesen
ersten durchbruch reagiert gerade schon
mit seinem schwarzen mit sehen camburg
haben wir die bild schaltung aber noch
nicht eine ton ist das natürlich auch
komplett verboten safe leute im
fernsehen zug war zigarette zu rauchen
in der in der tagesschau geht natürlich
gar nicht so selbstverständlich nicht
und der hat kein ton
wir schalten kurz vor chile hier sehen
sie einen netten mitarbeiter von uns
wieder an einer zigarette zieht ton habe
nicht für sie macht ihm keiner gesagt
dass die ganze show für sich war
ausfüllt und als übergangslösung auch
der thüringische ministerpräsident vogel
den fraktions post nun ist der
finanzexperte merz im geschmack
komplette geht auch noch nach rechts
durch das mir einen komplett sie aber
ganz ehrlich frage jetzt ne frage ich
will einfach trage ich will es auch
nicht hätten brauche hier mit dem
gestreiften hemd was ist deine mission
brauchst du brauchst du vielleicht ein
hörgerät die tagesschau -sprecherin
sitzt neben dir egal selbst wenn du
nicht hören kannst selbst wenn du sie
über hören kannst siehst doch dass du
stehst hier drei meter neben ihr steht
die tagesschau -sprecherin spricht in
die kamera
es ist doch klar dass die sendung live
ist und erst diese zewa packen werde ich
jetzt auffüllen und wenn ich meinen job
kostet
das virus auch professionell auf jeden
fall leute das video geht noch soviel
lang weiter ich habe sich als erster den
die beschreibung reingepackt richtig
geil heute richtig spaß gehabt da war
ich hoffe ihr auch die wahl
vorgeschlagen zu ihr habt aber nicht um
einen kanal ich höre schon raus macht
gut und jeder zweite kunde